Speaker 1: Let's talk about something I've said
for a long time, and now it's coming from inside
the House, inside the Republican House. That is a
Republican consultant reportedly working for the
Pennsylvania gubernatorial. Republican candidate
Doug Mastriano says Jews are not welcome in the
conservative movement. Well, yeah, I've been
telling you that for a long time. We're going to
talk about this. This is a very, very interesting
situation that's going on. The Jerusalem Post
reports Jews and non-Christians are not part
of the conservative movement, according to
a Republican candidate consultant. This is about
Doug Mastriano and an adviser named Andrew Torba.
Jews and other non-Christians are not conservative
because it is an explicitly Christian movement,
says Andrew Torba, the CEO of GAB. That's a right
wing platform and reportedly a consultant for
State Senator Doug Mastriano, who is indeed the
Republican candidate for governor of Pennsylvania.
Mastriano has come in to the public eye
in recent weeks after U.S. media outlets
reported he spent five grand advertising
on GAB. That's a social media network
favored by the far right. The candidate has also
reportedly paid for campaign consulting from GAB
with reports that new GAB users are set to
automatically follow mastriano. Both Republicans
and Democrats have called for Mastriano to
withdraw his ad from the social media platform.
Torba claimed many candidates are running
campaigns on GAB, although he didn't name them.
This is the most important election of the 2022
midterms because Doug is an outspoken Christian,
said Torba. We are going to build a
coalition of Christian nationalists,
of Christians, of Christian candidates at the
state, local and federal levels. And we're going
to take this country back for the glory of God. My
policy is not to conduct interviews with reporters
who aren't Christian. Give me a break. Torba
called Mastriano, his opponent, Josh SHAPIRO, who,
by the way, is Jewish. A Soros puppet, a reference
to Jewish billionaire George Soros and reiterated
claims that he was involved in voter fraud in
the 2020 election. This is a Christian movement.
All right. So, listen, this should not come
as a surprise to anybody in the audience.
One of the most liberal voting groups is
Jews. Another very liberal voting group
is black Americans, and in both cases,
more with black Americans than with Jews.
When Republicans are confronted with this fact,
hey, 88% of Jews voted for the Democrat. Hey,
88% of black Americans voted for the Democrat.
They go, Oh, they're brainwashed. Sometimes
they'll say, they're on the on the what was it?
They're on the plantation. Some of them would say,
no, actually, it's that Jews and black folks have
looked at the two parties and from the choices
have realized, Oh, voting for Democrats is more
in line with our interests. It's more logical.
Republicans don't really seem to like us
very much. And I've been saying for years,
when Republicans talk about Judeo-Christian
values and this is a Judeo-Christian country,
they don't mean that. That's pandering and
it's posturing to make it seem as though
it's not just Christianity that they care
about. So when you see people like Ben SHAPIRO,
Jared Kushner, this guy, Boris EPSHTEYN, Mark
Levin, the guy from Fox News, I assume he's Jewish
from from his name, although I don't know for
sure. These are essentially useful idiots.
They love to say stuff about how the real
racism, the real anti-Semitism and all this
stuff is actually on the left. Now there is
anti-Semitism on the left. It's different than
the anti-Semitism on the right. And I've talked
about it before. I don't shy away from that.
But they are useful idiots for a movement that at
the end of the day only reluctantly accepts them.
If they are 100% in line with the talking
points that they are supposed to repeat
useful idiot. I know it sounds like an insult.
It's a political term. A useful idiot is someone
who ends up propagandizing for a cause without
fully even realizing what the causes goals
are. You're cynically used by the leaders
and the vast majority of these right wing
Jews are being cynically used by the movement.
We've talked about this when you've got
gay conservatives and oh, well, we agree
about low taxes and blah, blah, blah, it's
very much the same sort of thing. And so I haven't
actually seen what the reaction to this has been
from the right wing Jews. My guess is they would
say something like horror but doesn't speak for
the right wing movement. And I can disagree with
Torba. Or maybe he was taken out of context or
whatever. I don't know. I'm guessing they would
equivocate in some way rather than saying,
Man, I'm part of a movement that basically
hates me. They're probably not going to
just cop to it in that way. But I've been
talking about this for a very long time,
and this is just the reality. And whether or
not, you know, the ad is pulled from gab doesn't
really make a difference about how Jewish folks
and many other groups to be. To be clear, this
particular stories about Jewish folks are seen
by very large swaths of the right wing movement.